- What's up? We're back with Selena Gomez!
(crowd cheering)
Her new Apple TV plus documentary
is called Selena Gomez My Mind & Me,
and we figured, what's on our minds a lot
of the time is of course, the
things we're obsessed with.
So, it's time for another round of-
(gentle music)
- [Announcer] Obsessions.
(crowd cheering)
- All right.
Some people's obsessions
can be a little different.
So what we'll do is I'll hit this button
and a topic will be selected
by our super computer.
'Cause we're rich.
That topic will be
something either Selena or I
are obsessed with
because the computer can read minds
(Selena laughs)
Totally.
Once the topic pops
up, the person obsessed
with the topic will sell us
on whatever it is they love.
I'll get us started with
something I apparently love
which is hilarious because
I didn't choose these.
My really good friend Trisha did.
So we'll see what it says.
Yeah.
(roulette spinning)
(bell dings)
(laughter)
- That's you girl.
- Oh, my God.
She called me out.
- Yep.
- Okay. I don't know how
to explain this (laughing)
- You got it.
- Okay. Feminine product (laughing)
Doomsday prepping.
Okay, here's the thing.
I, look, I like to be prepared.
- Hmm.
- Okay?
- Yeah.
- Global pandemic.
Who was ready?
This kid.
- [Selena] Yes.
- I had dry food, freeze dried food.
Look, I don't like to
say doomsday prepper.
I just like to say a girl--
a grown-ass girl scout.
(laughter)
(audience cheering)
Like, I'm prepared.
I'm a grown-ass girl
scout, and I'm prepared.
And here's the thing you don't think of.
As I was thinking when I was
like, storing all my stuff
just in case and I'm
like, well that happens.
So I'm gonna need,
and here's the thing that
Trisha is making fun of me for.
Do you ever order things and
you think you're getting like
you know, a box and it's like, this big.
- [Selena] Yeah.
- But then 10 come.
- Yes, that has happened many times.
- [Kelly] Well that's
the universe. That's God.
He wants me to be stored and stocked up.
So I have, so my friends make fun of me
because I literally have a
billion tampons in my garage.
(audience laughing)
(Selena laughing)
- But you know what,
when in doubt
- You're prepared, girl!
- Tampons are also good for
like minor cuts, whatever,
and a scrape, if you
don't have anything else.
So I'm just saying, you know what
Trisha for the win on this one, okay.
(audience cheering)
(Kelly laughing)
Oh my God. That's my favorite thing ever.
Okay, your turn.
- Okay.
(roulette spinning)
- [Announcer] Obsessions!
(bell dings)
- [Kelly] Oh!
- [Selena] This is mine.
- That's not weird.
- It isn't weird, because
if you're from the South
you understand that pickles are
a part of our life, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah, and the juice-
- Bread and butter..
- After you, it's like
the cherry on top
- Love it.
- So growing up I would go to
this little snow cone stand
and they had pickle snow
cones with pieces of grape.
- [Kelly] God, my mouth is watering.
- [Selena] It was so good.
- Yeah
- [Selena] I don't know, but
every time I do it at home
my friends don't really like it.
And it's definitely not
good on a date to do.
- [Kelly] I'm 100, yeah,
your mouth (laughing)
I'm in.
I think that sounds awesome.
- [Selena] Yes, thank you.
- And why aren't snow
cones here is my question?
- I don't know.
I remember going to the
movies for the first time.
I'm like, "Can I have a pickle?"
And they're like, "What's that?"
- [Kelly] Yeah! You get
the large dill pickles-
- And they don't have pickles
- [Kelly] Yeah, that's weird.
- They didn't understand
- [Kelly] They do that
in the South.
Also what we do in the
South is snow cones.
Do you know how much people
here would love a snow cone?
- [Selena] Should we do it?
- Should we have a snow cone stand?
I'm just, I think a lot of people here
their bereaved childhood
just never had a snow cone.
Like it's a big thing.
And a pickle juice one
that could be named Selena.
That's the Selena.
Okay, we're gonna start a business.
All right, here I go again.
- I'm loving this.
- I'm very scared to do this.
(roulette spinning)
- [Announcer] Obsessions.
(bell dings)
(crowd laughing)
- Oh man, Trisha knows me so well.
Do I need to say more?
- No.
- It is like-
You know when you have
a really tight ponytail,
like if you played sports
growing up and then you-
the release, you know.
Or your bra ladies,
you take it off and it's like, Yeah
- Yeah
- Yeah.
Spanks-
now, depending on the time
and how you are physically
they either roll off
or you could take them off either way.
But it's just, it's a free
you feel like a sausage being freed
from it's casing.
- I actually had to cut mine off.
- Oh, I love my turn.
Okay. Your turn.
(music)
(roulette spins)
- [Announcer] Obsessions.
(bell dings)
- I just did one.
- You like them together?
- Oh good.
- Literally like a day ago.
- Did you win?
- Escaped with three minute,
a little over three minutes left.
- That's I'm saying.
- Yes. Yes.
I love escape rooms.
- Okay. I've-
I've counted so far I've done
almost eighty escape rooms.
- Because you do it on tour?
- I did it on tour
- Yes.
- But I ha-
I will do four in a night.
Like I will be wiped.
My friends are like, Let's go out.
And I'm like, I'm gonna lock my myself
in a room
and just try to find my way out.
And my friends are like,
Why does that sound fun?
- It is.
- I just, I love it.
I think it's so, it gets me stimulated.
I feel accomplished and...
- Yeah.
- Are you good at it?
Are you really good at it?
- I'm not that good at it.
- Me Neither. Me neither.
But it's like bowling really.
You just like to be there, you know?
- Yeah, I'm happy to be there.
- It's a good time. It's a good hang.
I love it too.
It's amazing how you see your friends too,
how they operate in that environment.
- Mm hmm, Totally.
I take it serious though.
I'm like, Guys, we're in a movie.
You're playing the lead character.
- Yeah.
- I somehow get lost, you know? - Yeah.
- I make it a whole scenario.
- Yeah. Oh, I'm totally into.
We all just did it, the band.
We were all there, yep, anyway.
Okay. Those are our
- Obsessions.
(crowd cheering)
- [Announcer] Obsessions.
- We should, Selena was singing with you.
Y'all just sang a duet.
Selena Gomez,
My mind & me is on Apple TV plus now.
Y'all have to watch it.
It's so good.
Selena Gomez, everybody.
Give it up.
(crowd cheering)